my name is Katrina real I am the
President of the board of directors
right now I've been on the on the board
for the last four and a half years I
became the president a year and a half
ago and um my story is you know my PhD
is in computer science with a specialty
in artificial intelligence and I got
involved in open source while I was a
graduate student which is pretty common
for most graduate students actually
that's the Dirty Little Secret of OSS
right is that it's built on the backs of
all of The Graduate students and we um I
got involved in all these open source
projects and then
um you know the thing about open source
is that you know no one's getting paid
it's a labor of love people put their
code out there you know they're
maintaining it they're you know fixing
bugs they're doing all these things and
it's you know it's for sure a labor of
love but also there's a great deal of
instability back then so when people
would graduate they would go get a
mortgage and a job and have some kids
and life happens and things like that
generally you know a lot of projects
would fail so income's numb focused the
idea here is that we provide a
non-profit organization that can help
maintain and have kind of a home for
projects and be able to create more
stability so that includes Financial
stability as well as infrastructure
stability as well as Community stability
and so
uh I myself am you know I'm no longer a
code contributor but um might be again
soon I actually just took over Pi Vis on
Monday and
um uh other than that I am a lecturer at
Georgetown University
um teaching data visualization so that's
my whole story and uh welcome to numb
Focus so like I said you've probably
heard of our projects there are a lot
out there this is a really really
popular ecosystem we have 50 fiscally
sponsored projects and by fiscally
sponsored that's a term that's actually
a legal term that means that we are the
fiscal entity for those projects and
I'll get into that a little bit more the
Affiliated projects we have 60 of those
actually so in total we have 110
projects that we're helping to move
across the line if you can possibly
imagine and that includes you know like
I said you know kind of the big five is
always you know numpy scipy Panda
scikit-learn Jupiter
um uh I I apologize but like I said
these are there's so many within this
community that's almost impossible to go
all the way down the line
um and we're always taking applications
by the way so Affiliated project status
we do go through a process where people
have to meet certain stancers standards
we are code of conduct that has to be
adopted
um there's definitely a certain amount
of community that has to be there and
diversity has to happen inside of the
projects and over on the fiscal side if
you become a fiscally sponsored project
generally that means that we're handling
some sort of Grant Administration or
corporate donations or some sort of
money Changing Hands basically and we
are the um like I said the fiscal entity
that handles that
so these projects like I said they are
everywhere we've seen them in business
primarily right but I do want to mention
you know the the core mission of numb
focus is scientific Computing that's
where it really came out of and
primarily mostly also in like the
astrophysics area
um there's a lot of work done in that
area and
um the idea of having repeatable science
good tools that are available
democratized data things like that are
all Core Concepts with Beyond this and
so some of the impact that we've made
out there I mean the James Webb
Telescope all the pictures that you've
seen there the black hole picture that
was all over the place that was you know
processed with numpy and scipy and
pandas and astropi the ligo Nobel prize
winning uh gravitational wave detector
obviously that was using a whole bunch
of uh um the stack you see these
packages and everything you know OS X
Azure machine learning I mean just go
down the line
all the platforms that you've probably
worked with have these packages in them
we've enabled a lot of businesses to be
able to do their jobs basically because
they have these software tools available
to them
um fighting human trafficking I have to
call that one out because that's my
project the memex project where we were
working with DARPA actually to hunt down
human trafficking rings on the dark web
which was really really fun if you're
actually interested in that check me out
on YouTube
um and obviously there was a lot going
on in there we're actually partnered um
at the time uh Anaconda was called
Continuum analytics that's where I
worked and so um we were primarily
involved in um actually driving new
features into the open source projects
in order to develop what we were doing
because it was pretty Cutting Edge what
we were we were trying to push forward
on that project
and then obviously we have a lot of
Partnerships and so the institute for
ethical AI machine learning there's a
lot of work around that partnering with
them
uh let's see so why should you support
open source obviously I am a big
advocate of Open Source I talk about
open source all the time but why is this
important and I you know I'm pitching to
companies a lot and trying to explain
why this is such an important part of
what we do and if you think about it
these open source projects are part of
our infrastructure at this point if a
project like numpy were to fall over and
fail which all of the projects basically
in this entire ecosystem rely upon
imagine that would be catastrophic it
would actually be a um you know a you
know a government defense issue I mean
it actually our entire country's
infrastructure would have trouble
running as a result of that not to
mention businesses right and so these
are um you know really important
obviously and so um why would you want
to support open source first off
research development costs go down that
happens quite a bit we've seen that over
and over and over again there have been
studies in this area
recruiting and retaining top talent this
is one um I've recently stopped working
and doing open source full-time now but
when I was a manager and director I was
recruiting heavily from the open source
Community because you find amazing
talent out there and who are already
familiar with the entire stack and be
able to pull them in
uh as a part of that you also have this
uh sort of bigger picture engagement
that happens when people feel that
they're a part of an open source project
there is sort of a bigger than me sense
that happens right but um they're a part
of something bigger than what they're
just working on in their day-to-day job
and so that tends to cause more job
satisfaction peoples tend to stay and
then also just you know having sort of
continuity in their um in their vision
of where they want their career to go
and over and over and over again I've
been told you know most of my manager
trainings right if you don't have a path
forward for your employees they will
leave you right and so you have to be
able to have those career opportunities
and those development opportunities
available because it's competitive out
there good top talent they're being
poached everywhere they go right and so
you want to be able to to keep them on
your team obviously this is better for
business
um I mean you can look at statistics all
over the place around this um I try to
you know my best example here is that if
you look like every time you turn around
you see another
um you know
startup that's basically built
completely on scikit-learn right like
you think about all the businesses that
have you know bloomed out of this
ecosystem and all of these developers
and all these people working in this
area
um it's good for all of us in order for
us to be able to support new businesses
be able to support an ecosystem and also
for us to be able to support you know
the economy quite frankly and so I also
want to add one more on there is um
supporting open source because of the
democratization of education
so I've recently become a lecturer over
at Georgetown University and I'm more
and more aware of this the ability to be
able to teach with open source tools and
put things in people's hands is
essential right so um getting people you
know involved is just you build skills
you get good at what you're doing and
then for people like me you know um I
grew up you know relatively economically
disadvantaged and being able to be in an
open source Community I learned how to
code by some of the best programmers in
the world right maybe not always in the
most kind way but definitely coached by
some of the very best programmers in the
world and I've relished that opportunity
to be able to get that feedback and so
um being able to build a career
not necessarily based on you know which
school you go to like which you know big
company you work for things like that I
think is essential kind of levels the
playing field quite a bit because
whoever puts up the code first is the
winner right so those who do the work
and so I always appreciated that
democratization of development quite a
bit
all right so why do we have dumb Focus I
kind of talked a little bit about this
um obviously you know funding is a big
deal everybody needs money we all have
bills to pay we all have things that we
need to do
um stability
um like I mentioned before you know with
projects that would kind of come and go
this was a big problem more than 10
years ago numb focus is this is our 11th
year
and so um last year was our 10th year
our big celebration of 10 years of numb
focus and
um before that it really was the Wild
West I've worked on a lot of Open Source
projects over the years and I would say
you know that a lot of them failed most
of them failed in fact and they would
just kind of be abandoned and just kind
of out there we do provide some
stability we also make sure that there
are governance docs in available
available
um we provide a central Hub that allows
the continuity so for projects to link
together and support each other
um we also are an independent entity so
we are a you know we can function as a
neutral unbiased and independent
organization of all the open source
projects and this comes up quite a bit
we don't kind of get into that a little
bit more when we talk about code of
conduct and issues that pop up there
um so we also the logistical support we
take the administrative Financial
logistical responsibilities of
sustaining an open source project out of
the hands of the project contributors so
people who are really technically
inclined are able to focus on the things
that they do best basically and we can
handle the parts that you know nobody
wants to handle the accounting and
Financial and Taxes and all of those fun
things that go on in the background
all right so uh
like I mentioned uh
we provide a lot of fiscal and legal
services every project that joins num
Focus has a certain number of hours of
legal
consultation that they can use this pops
up more than you might think actually
because things like trademark
infringement is a big deal as you can
imagine that there are companies that
may want to take one of the logos and
use it as their own logo and kind of
assume that there's an affiliation
between this new company and an open
source project num Focus does own all
the trademarks on all of the projects
that's part of our fiscal responsibility
so we do send occasionally you know
seasoned assist letters where like hey
you can't do that this is not this is
not open obviously we don't have a
problem with people using logos and
presentations at conferences and things
like that I always feel the need to like
explain that to people just make sure
that the Integrity of the logos is
maintained and you know we want people
to understand we want people to know
about projects and use them
um so uh it's not about that but really
just making sure that you know no one's
being taken advantage of I think is the
biggest deal but we also have you know
some things that have even wound up in
the news where we've had to get involved
with um you know claims that have been
made on projects or you know claims that
proprietary code wound up in open source
repositories
um things like that where we have had to
get involved or licensing issues is
another thing that comes up quite a bit
when projects join uh num Focus they do
have to have an OSI approved open source
license primarily most people are using
you know BSD MIT you know Apache
licenses those are generally The Big
Three that we see but there are a whole
list of them by the way and there are
some that are a little bit controversial
so
um you know I'm not a lawyer but at the
same time you know I am part of the
entity that reviews everybody's licenses
and if we do have a problem with it you
know we will ask people to make sure
that they have a license that's in
compliance with the values of of num
Focus before they join the community and
so we protect the co the projects that
way you know with legal representation
um so sustainability we engage with the
projects quite a bit
um we ask what their needs are we have a
whole lot of you know events things like
that where people are able to share
knowledge
um we have you know slack channels and
you know mailing lists and newsletters
and pretty much everything that you can
possibly imagine trying to bring the
community together
um so those are a lot of you know the
things that we do and then also
obviously within Community this is a big
part of what we do obviously
um and there you have both your user
community and you also have your
developer Community both of them are
just as important as the other one
obviously the open source communities
you know the people who are developing
software they don't have anything to do
if they're no users right nobody wants
to write software that nobody else is
using right so how do you connect users
and developers together and get them
talking to each other because they don't
always have the same skill sets right
you know things like um bouquet if
anyone's familiar with that one for
example right is primarily written in
JavaScript it's a python to JavaScript
translator more than anything right that
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
going to be the person you know who's an
expert at using it in data visualization
right or the person who's in data
visualization may be able to even have
the skills to be able to write the
JavaScript that would require them to be
a core contributor right but there does
have to be a conversation happening
between the two right and so we kind of
help with some of that Community
Building both on the user side as well
as on the developer side
especially through education and
Outreach and I'll talk about that a
little bit more
um
all right so our fiscal and legal
services are provided through our fiscal
sponsorship program
IPython by the way was our first
fiscally sponsored project it was the
number one it received corporate funding
and it went through num focus and so
we're the ones who pay the bills and
invoices and developers and everything
that comes through there everybody that
would be on that um getting money from
that corporate funding so how this works
so
once the money comes in we're the ones
who are gonna we hold the bank account
and we also are the ones who are going
to sign all the contracts and legal
documents so we make sure that the
projects are covered like everything is
all up and up and above board
um then we are the person who will
handle you know invoices vendors
suppliers anything that comes in make
sure everybody gets paid and then
everybody also has their accounting
available for non-profit organizations
all of our accounting is open we have to
be able to report that to the US
government other countries we are Global
organizations so other countries have
different requirements we do take care
of that as well so the idea being that
we will help you know projects be able
to handle their fiscal responsibilities
and continue to just do the code right
and make sure that they are working on
the technology
um and then of course you know the last
one disbursement of funds right so this
could be the project leadership team
contract agreements donors things like
that and then of course we do donor
reporting like I said we have to be able
to keep that open and you know I was
recently working on a contract or
working with a fiscally sponsored
project that was based out of the UK
they do have different reporting
structures over there so that's why this
recently just came up but here in the us
if we were the grant
administrator regardless of the fact
that they were in the UK we would still
have to be able to do all the same donor
reporting in the US because we're a U.S
entity primarily
all right so
I kind of talked about this a little bit
already but
um like I said licensing trademark
registration ownership you know
contracts and agreements our financial
services so accounts and Grant
Administration and contractor agreements
um taxes of reporting we also by the way
review all these things for people if we
feel like people are being taken
advantage of we're going to bring it up
we will do contract negotiations we will
help with um uh you know Grant proposals
we will help with um you know even
connecting people to sources of funding
if we can do it so everything that comes
in you know we're really trying as much
as possible it's all about the projects
trying to make sure that they're out in
front and that they're getting all the
support that they need
and then of course the operational
Services
um so everyone who's a fiscal entity
inside of
numb focused like I said you know their
trademarks and agreements and everything
we are the fiscal entity that's you know
in charge of all of that but we also do
provide some technical infrastructure so
slack channels all the websites move
over
um we uh have a whole web team that
handles all the website Administration
and we make sure that it's behind you
know cloudflare and all the good things
you know make sure everything is secure
and so we'll handle all of that and then
of course conference and event planning
if any of you have been to a pi data
conference those are ours those are what
we do and that's the primary way that we
make money actually to offset the cost
of all of these surfaces that we give to
the projects so that's a money making
opportunity like I said that allows us
to charge lower fees to the projects for
all the services that we do for them
um and then also obviously uh Consulting
on a variety of administration requests
um I come in to help a lot actually with
um just making sure that I mean
everything from
mediation to contract negotiations we'll
we'll get involved if anybody needs help
that's what we're here for
all right so how do we make sure that
our projects are sustainable one of the
big ones is governance docs every
project has to have governance dogs so
that it's very very clear how decisions
are made who is in charge who are the
people that are going to be responsible
when somebody comes in on a fiscally
sponsored project we also require four
signatories that have to be from
different organizations and we do this
so that first off that means that the
project is actually open and it's also
means that there is enough diversity
that if one area fails that we have you
know basically other entities that are
going to be able to take over in the
event of any kind of governance issues
that pop up and this happens quite a bit
right people leave people come in people
try to do different things you have new
maintainers that come in that may have a
different idea of how the project should
run or how a pull requests should be
done or something like that and people
come and go but you have to make sure
that's very very clear how the project
runs and how decision are made
so moving on for that project management
corporate engagement Community Support
code of contact issues this is a big one
that comes in for us is that everybody
who's associated with non-pocus has to
be um have has to have an active code of
conduct if you put in a code of conduct
report they are Anonymous or they can be
anonymous on our website they go to
they're handled primarily within the
board of directors so it stays very very
contained even if you have a problem
with somebody on the num focused staff
you know we try to handle it as
independently and without bias as we
possibly can and this is what you know
trying to build a more diverse and
inclusive contributor Community out of
that
and so also with Community you know not
just owning the trademarks and branding
and things like that but we also want to
make sure that people know who the
projects are right I mean everybody's
heard of the big five you know that you
know that are used everywhere you know
pandas and scikit-learn and numpy and
scipy and everything like that but like
I said you know there are 110 projects
in here and I think that some people
have never even heard of most of them
right we want to make sure that they are
out there and that people are aware of
what they're doing
um a lot of them are doing some pretty
amazing work actually I'm always really
surprised to see like all the grant
money is really being good used for
amazing science to be quite honest and
um yeah definitely want to make sure
that that is protected and that we're
getting the name out there
all right so
project sustainability two of the things
that we have going on I'll just mention
the small development grants first
um so the idea of small development
grants is that um this is a way for us
to directly give money to projects so we
have money that people can apply for
they have a project that generally is
too small to be covered by some sort of
corporate entity or through a
foundational support so things like you
know we work very closely with Chan
Zuckerberg and the Sloan Foundation
Gordon Betty Moore Foundation things
like that these are generally pretty big
grants that come in to the open source
projects but that means that they have
to have a road map that kind of follows
and it's been approved but for the money
what that money is going to be used for
sometimes you have something that just
needs to be done that is just so small
scale you can't run it through a big
foundation they're not going to approve
it right they're they're they're just
bigger than that and so having something
where it's like you know we really
really need better documentation can we
apply for a summer intern to come in and
just fix our documentation they can
apply for a small development Grant you
know does the project need to meet up
and have a Sprint for three days
somewhere where they just go heads down
on something right they can apply for a
small development Grant or is there some
contained feature that no one else
really wants that is necessary or
security vulnerability that needs to be
covered they can apply for a small
development Grant so they can actually
pay people to work on it
in 2022 we did award about 220 000
directly to projects and like I said you
know that money comes in from all the
educational work that we do and things
like that but um The Hope is that we're
actually going to try and make that even
bigger now that we have live events
coming on coming on again and the hope
is that we're going to be able to do
more in that area the project Summit is
pretty exciting this is where we bring
all of the projects together it's By
Invitation Only where two days of
intensive workshops with all the
maintainers from all the projects there
it's actually pretty cool so we talk
about you know people will talk about
where they get sources of funding
they'll talk about coding standards
they'll talk about you know new
technologies that are coming out
cross-collaboration that might happen
and it's just a great way for people to
kind of get to know each other and um
so obviously some of the past workshops
have included things from governance
roadmaps and diversity inclusion are big
areas
um and then going on to our community so
so why is there a deed for ongoing
interaction with the community and the
greater public why is promotion of a
product branding so important right
first off they're fundraising
opportunities if no one knows who your
project is and it's not out there nobody
knows that they can give you money they
don't know to go look for you there's
nothing they don't know who to go Google
right
um so a ongoing source of new project
contributors and users right I mentioned
before that we have a developer
community that we're supporting but we
have a user community that we're trying
to support as well and we want to make
sure that basically you know we have to
have people that people move on and off
projects you know they're not employed
mostly by most of these projects so
people move on and you have to have new
people that are coming in and I'll add
to that that in Num Focus we have to
have people who are active in the
community that could move into helping
us run num Focus you know I'm a
technical person like I'm full-blown you
know like Code Monkey whatever like you
know I had to learn all this stuff
coming in but it's worth it because I
really want to make sure that the
community stays healthy but we do need
people that are able to kind of move
into that area as well so creating those
pipelines is important
obviously we want to make sure that we
get user feedback
um and then how do we do this the
biggest thing is our conference is I
mentioned that the pi data conferences
are just you know all over
um so during the pandemic unfortunately
we got hit pretty hard
um so we had to move online so I'll talk
about that in a minute and then we also
have membership fees that come in we
have the newsletter that's going out we
have meetups and we have you know blog
posts things like that
um so mention the educational programs
conferences workshops Sprints and
hackathons we participate in Google
summer of code every single year so a
lot of projects are not big enough in
order to be able to participate on their
own but we will help projects come
together and and participate under the
num Focus name we have videos meetups
digital communities and Destiny check
out our YouTube channel there's just a
ton of good information out there every
single talk from every Pi data
conference is out there and if you ever
want to watch funny videos of me that's
another good place to watch me talk
about technical things for once
um but uh it's uh definitely check it
out the YouTube channel for pi data TV
it's definitely it's worth a look
okay so Pi data is the educational arm
of numb Focus most people are more
familiar with pi data than they are numb
focused but we are the people behind it
is this is the same it is just the
education piece so this is the one that
is supposed to help bring our user and
develop our communities together and
have that conversation of like where
projects need to go make sure that
people are aware of new features that
are coming out getting feedback from
users on what's important to them those
kinds of things I think has to have a
forum
and so before the pandemic I didn't want
to change the slide because I was just
so we were just so proud of this before
the pandemic we actually had 16
conferences every single year worldwide
so we're kicking off Live Events again
so we kicked off with uh Pi data London
um last fall and that was our first live
event since the pandemic had started and
then we had Pi Day to New York which I
was there for that one we apply date of
Berlin which I think is actually
happening right now
um I'll plug for Pi Day to Seattle if
you're interested in going up there um
you'll see me there as well and so um
it's really it's nice to have these
coming up because all of the proceeds
like I said are put back into the
projects and it's a really important
funnel for us
our grant Administration fees are very
very low so compared to like a
university like I used to work here at
UT Austin okay at the applied Research
Laboratories their fees on a grant
that's coming in from the government
upwards of 50 of the money that's coming
in so you have a lot of money that's
going directly to Administration and
overhead
our fees during the pandemic we had to
raise them to 15 we're actually lowering
them back down to the original 10
percent right now because we have live
events coming back online but the idea
is that we want to keep the money in the
pockets of the developers we want people
to have as much money as possible to
keep their projects going and so having
a fiscal entity that can provide you
know these services for so so cheap as
opposed to institutions that you know
I'm not trying to say anything about the
institutions they have huge overhead for
a number of reasons but at the same time
having an alternative especially for
non-profit and open source where you
know everything is not going through a
corporate entity is very important
right and so
um you know 425
000 goes a really really long way when
you're giving money to open source
projects and you saw that 220 000 of
that you know if you want to think of
that as going directly back to the
projects through the small development
Grant
um my goal My Wish actually as president
of the board of directors I would love
if we could offer zero percent I would
love to just give 100 of the money over
to the projects
um but we do have to you know figure out
another income stream in order to make
that happen I think so we'll work on
that
um the pi data meetups this is actually
an old picture we have over 180 B-Dubs
all over the all over the world Pi data
is trademarked so if there is a pi data
Meetup that pops up we'll reach out to
them because we do want to make sure
that we're maintaining the Integrity of
the pi data Community make sure that
they have adopted our code of conduct
make sure that they are aware of like
kind of the standards the community
standards that we would require to have
something branded with pi data
um but uh like I said 180 and growing
all the time and you may have noticed
there's no dot on Pi data Austin that's
my
yeah
um that's because I was running it I got
really busy but uh I own the Meetup site
for pie day to Austin check it out and
hopefully I'll get that up and running
again soon but
um if we anyone has a venue that they
want to donate space for
um when I I quit working recently um I'm
basically retired now and I don't have a
space anymore because I don't work
anywhere so if anyone has a space for us
I'll just put that plug in there right
now
um I'm more than happy to start a backup
but you know here in Austin you know
there are is a very vibrant python
Community here in Austin you know
Anaconda is located here Quant site is
located here I moved to Austin because I
started working at nthot after I
finished my PhD there's a lot there's a
lot of python activity in this area and
so um
we're actually going to be taking over
the Sci-Fi conference this year so that
will also be coming through
coming through num Focus From Now On
which will take place here at the at T
Center by the way so
um definitely check it out it's first
week of July
all right so behind the scenes who makes
this happen you'd be surprised how small
our staff is we have almost we have we
run on a shoe strict budget for sure
um there is no there there's no give in
our budget whatsoever because every
single penny that we can possibly give
we do so if that involves you know
diversity scholarships you know small
development grants bringing projects
together making sure that we could have
our Summit
um you know every single year making
sure that we are um you know have legal
services everything we try to give back
as much as possible so the staff is
actually only about a dozen people
believe it or not and that's for you
know all this entire community
the board of directors what I'm on we
have currently seven Board of director
member nine if you include our uh our
executive director who is on the board
but non-voting
um we're all volunteers I get paid
nothing to do all this believe it or not
um our advisory Council a lot of that is
a lot of the founders of some of the big
projects you know so like Fernando Perez
um you know Travis Oliphant Peter Wang
is on there there are a lot of people in
the python community that are on our
advisory Council also unpaid all
volunteers right we have a diversity
inclusion scientific Computing committee
that is also all volunteers right
they're starting to see this pattern
right
um Affiliated project committee also
volunteers and a small development Grant
committee also volunteers and I also
just want to mention you know all of the
pi data events we're talking about this
a little bit before I started my session
that is all volunteer driven so all the
people that are running the pi data
events our program committees everybody
who's running the event doing the AV you
know introducing everyone no one's paid
right and it's all so that we can raise
money to offset the cost of projects for
all of their expenses to keep running
and so um definitely very very valuable
to have our volunteers but I mean if I
were to count I mean between you know
people running the websites people
handing AWS credits people who are
handling you know devops for us people
who are looking at our financial systems
people who are you know donating legal
time you know to us
um we we have hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of volunteers who make this
possible
um and it's just it's amazing and you
know just a huge thank you to everybody
for that
but um I guess the last thing I wanted
to talk about was you know getting
involved in numb Focus you would be
surprised how difficult it is to find
sustainable funding for open source
projects I always describe it to people
that I think everyone thinks that
someone else is supporting an open
source project right that's like you
know when you see a fire and you assume
that everybody else called 9-1-1 and
actually turns out nobody nobody called
9-1-1 it's because
um everyone assumes that projects like
numpy are rich but you know this money
is just coming in and flowing through
but finding sustainable
sustainable corporate money and
foundational money educational money is
huge we can't we cannot stress this
enough that um we need donations so
badly
um I donate personally every single year
um we take corporate donations all sorts
of sponsorship opportunities for pi data
events everything like that but you'd be
surprised that this is something that
every single year we spend a great deal
of time raising money because it's never
sustainable if we could find some sort
of way to you know make this constant
rather than having to kind of scramble
every single year I think it would just
be amazing and a lot of people are very
surprised when they find out how how
difficult it is for us to find money
um another thing is just advocating
right making sure that open source
Advocates are important just being out
there making sure that people are
respecting the Integrity of the
community that people are learning more
about the projects that are out there
and using them in their code
um volunteering like I mentioned
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
volunteers um just for everything you
can possibly imagine and then
contributing code obviously we always
need coach contributors and I tell
people quite often you know best way to
ever get into an open source project and
I'll just go ahead and plug this right
now if you you know kind of need a door
in the magic is documentation nobody's
gonna stop you from writing
documentation and putting in a pull
request they will in fact love you and
remember your name forever and be super
happy when you become a core contributor
so that's that's the backdoor way to get
into like almost every open source
project by the way but for sure check
out the numfocus.org support page that's
where you can find out all about all
those things and then also as far as
donations we do have giving at
numfocus.org that you can go to you can
email to and that'll put you in touch
with our executive director and our our
head fundraiser and then I think that's
it so just please check us out
nymphocus.org and uh thank you so much
for your attention
foreign
[Applause]
thank you Katrina
oh wait hold on let me get you
great oh thanks for the presentation
um I have a question because I notice
like uh in like different areas of like
the field of data you'll see things like
numb focus in the scientific area and
data science and then in the more like
data engineering modern data stack
companies you see a pattern of
um a team creating an open source
project and then creating a company
that's Enterprise support for it and
then they're the ones driving the
roadmap they're the ones contributing to
that code and like that project I'm
curious like what your thoughts are on
the what what differences emerge in
those open source projects because of
like the places that they get their
funding yeah you're going to get a very
highly uh Katrina colored uh answer to
this question
um because everyone has different you
know views on like how open open source
should be right
um I'm definitely lean more towards the
very open side okay and a lot of people
I think within num Focus especially in
the open source Community probably tend
a little bit more towards the Practical
side right that we are you know we do
have to have people who are driving road
maps we do have to be able to pay our
bills things like that but like I
mentioned in fiscally sponsored projects
we do require signatories from different
from different entities so the idea
there actually is to prevent one
organization from driving the entire
roadmap Affiliated projects we don't
have that requirement one organization
can move something forward but that kind
of puts you in the area of like the
difference between open code and open
project right A lot of people have open
code
so you can see what's running on your
machine and you have access to it and
technically you can Fork it and create
whatever you want but they may or may
not ever accept a pull request from you
right because that they have such tight
hold on their project and so I would
consider that not to be a completely
open project personally and so
there is definitely you know this
spectrum we want to be as inclusive as
possible within the num Focus community
and that's the whole point of what we do
is that we want to create Community we
want to bring people in we want people
talking to each other we want to create
this community but at the same time
there does have to be a certain standard
of what is considered open and that is
the line that we draw between fiscally
sponsored and Affiliated is that you do
have to have those different entities
involved in order to be able to be an
open project and fiscally sponsored
any other questions
all right we do have office hours for
with Katrina immediately following this
it's in 102 B so it's right in the main
entrance hallway
let's give another round of applause
thank you so much Katrina we appreciate
you yeah and I just wanted to add that I
have stickers from most of the projects
so if you've ever been looking for your
favorite you know Jupiter sticker numpy
sticker scikit learn sticker numb Focus
stickers I have a ton of stickers in my
bag and so that will be another reason
to come to office hours because I've got
all the stickers for your laptops
all right thank you
[Music]